3 heavy nous avaient pris le départ du
vendée globe 2016 le 6 novembre dernier
des sables d'olonne ils ne sont plus que
deux en course le verset tanguy la mode
qui visait une place dans le top 10 sur
ce tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale et contraint à l'abandon
le navigateur a cassé sa tête demain au
nord du cap vert après avoir tenté de
réparer les dégâts près de deux jours
les viennois dû se rendre à l'évidence
et a décidé d'abandonner ce mardi 15
novembre
donc j'ai pris la décision difficile
avec mon équipe de ne pas aller
affronter les mers du sud avec un mât
dans cet état là et risquent de s'ouvrir
et c'est beaucoup trop dangereux d'aller
dans ces endroits il reste encore vingt
mille milles de course et j'ai pas envie
de risquer le sur accident donc mon sens
marin veut que je fasse demi tour vers
les sables d'olonne mais toujours dans
l'esprit du vendée globe c'est à dire
sans assistance sans escale et en
solitaire je ramène mon bateau à bon
port et c'est la meilleur moyen c'est le
meilleur moyen de boucler cette aventure
de son côté l'autre versailles et éric
bellion nos vies sur ce vendée globe est
positionné à la 22e place de la flotte
au pointage de 15 heures ce lundi 21
novembre après un peu plus de quinze
jours de course et moi j'ai envie un peu
de m'attarder sur ses bons difficile
voyez dans mon poste de veille
je vais encore me reposer un peu elle
est réelle sont tirées les mains aussi
sont marqués à mener le bateau jusque là
ça n'a pas été facile j'ai eu des
moments difficiles de fatigue de cafard
de moment où je pensais pas y arriver et
ça c'est très important d'en parler
parce que
l'inconnue laventure la différence tout
ça ça demande des sacrifices à demande
de l'effort ça demande un engagement
farouche ceux qui vous disent que c'est
du tout cuit que ça marche tout seul
c'est les gens qui n'essaie pas c'est
les gens qui font que parler lansade
manger vraiment une volonté farouche
vraiment farouche le 3ème évinois louis
burton est lui aussi arrivé dans
l'hémisphère sud après quelques frayeurs
au départ avec son imoca bureau vallée
le navigateur occupe la 13ème place
tout va bien à bord j'espère que
vous amuser à suivre cette course elle
est passionnante à courir en tout cas
c'est là où je passe le plus clair de
mon temps quand on va bien à bord et qui
a pas besoin les manoeuvres est donc à
l'abri de cette magnifique casquette
superbement préparé par l'équipe
le britannique alex thomson sur hugo
boss est pour l'instant en tête de la
flotte il devance sébastien josse et
armel le cléac'h le passage du cap de
bonne espérance est programmée pour la
fin de semaine